[Music]
I want my hair back I feel like Earth
twice but what happened to my mop it
went with my top and now I feel like poo
then it's because of you
how did you convince me this is not what
I want to see
I hate you you freakin son what happened
you cut your hair I'm so gonna
unsubscribe how did you think that this
mess on my head was stylish I look like
a kid
oh and only I could get what I wish
because if I can't then you'd be dead I
hate you
you freaking suck how did I do
I want my head back
I feel like it's watching what happened
to my wall it went or look like salt and
then I'm feeling
you convinced me this it's not what I
want to see and I'm pretty sure it's not
what you guys want to see either so for
now I'm just going to wear a beanie
until it grows back
[Music]
you
trust your trade though some kind of
dispute I think people would argue for
this man
you